كانت القضاء العشائريه
بها سنينه وسنه ثابته السنين يراد بها
القانون العشائري والقانون العشري كان
ثابت
ولكن في وقتنا الحاضر نادرا ما من
يتمسك
بالسنائن او السناين الاوليه
العشيره عباره عن حكومه صغيره
[موسيقى]
ولكن تختلف عن مفهوم الحكومه السياسيه
يؤمن مجلس القضاء الاعلى بالدور الذي
تلعبه العشائر العراقيه في المحافظه على
النسيج الاجتماعي في الحقيقه كلمه القضاء
الهمد والقانون خاص ولا يمكن ان تطلق على
اي تسويات تجري خارج اطار القانون او خارج
اطار المحاكم المختصه بموجب القوانين
النافذه في العراق فلا يوجد شيء اسمه
القضاء العشائري وانما هناك تسويات تتم
وتقوم بها العشائر العراقيه الكريمه في
الكثير من المنازعات التي تنشا بين
الافراد تنطلق من فكره اصلاح ذات البين
اللي ترسخت في المجتمع العراقي واللي اكد
عليها الدين الاسلامي الحنيف هذه التسويات
وهذه الترضيات تتم خارج نطاق المحاكم ولا
يمكن ان نطلق عليها تسميه القضاء العشائري
او القانون العشائري لا يوجد في العراق
قانون عشائري انما توجد اعراف
[موسيقى]
الستر والامن والامان بين قبيله
عطوان وقبيله اجبور نسلمها بالساده
يفتحها وهذا الشيء الشيخ ان شاء الله
ابو الفضل العباس الفصل واقع
والمقاسير واقعه افتح الرئيس الخاصير
والفصل كله طالب نهدي سوره الفاتحه على
نيه الرضا بين
طياح الفصل
والمخاسير كلها ان شاء الله اكراما لكل
الموجودين مسبوقه المبطلات على محمد وال
محمد
اللهم صل على محمد